because today is a day that ends in Y
President Trump is being accused by the
left of racism this time because he
pointed out that a horribly run and
incredibly dangerous City Baltimore is
horribly run and incredibly dangerous
nice right-wingers are lamenting the
mean tweets we will take a cold hard
look at whether the tweets are helping
or hurting Trump's case then the White
House wins big on the wall at the
Supreme Court and Attorney General
William Barr resumed executing criminals
for the first time in 16 years we will
examine why everybody hates the death
penalty these days and why it's actually
a wonderful institution all that and a
lot more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
is President Trump a racist I feel like
this could be the perpetual headline
because every day the left says he's
racist in this case some right-wingers
are calling him racist - and even the
right-wingers who aren't calling him
racist are saying that the tweets are
terrible and they need to stop I have a
little bit I guess of an unconventional
view on this so we will take a cold hard
look at all of those tweets why is
President Trump being accused of racism
he's being accused of racism because he
pointed out that Baltimore which I'm not
too far from right now I'm in Washington
DC so I'm a stone's throw from Baltimore
is one of the most crime and poverty
ridden cities in America and that is
largely thanks to corrupt politicians
now Democrats can't answer this charge
Democrats have run Baltimore for a very
very long time that the congressman who
represents Baltimore and and one of the
worst areas of Baltimore is has been
there for 36 years at this point and so
they can't answer Trump on the merits so
they call him racist this is what the
left always does nothing new there
what is new is President Trump's
response which is he's calling the left
racist right back he's just going right
for it he's not trying to play this down
he's not trying to avoid the issue he is
going for the jugular he is harping on
the issue and he's calling them racist
and that the question is who's right
who's racist and politically are the
tweets helping him or not now one thing
that the mainstream media have failed to
point out here is that in this fight as
is almost always the case with Trump the
Democrats started the fight Trump
continues the fight Trump maybe elevates
the fight or escalates the fight but as
is often the case with him his opponents
started he plays nice with people if
they play nice with him they start it
and then he pushes back punches back
twice as hard so specifically in this
case Elijah Cummings who was a Democrat
from Baltimore he's been in office for a
thousand years he's accomplished nothing
he started this fight coming started the
fight by screaming like a petulant
little child at the head of the
Department of Homeland Security on
television last week he Ria's when we
hear about stories coming out from
you and your agency that everything is
pretty good and you doing a great job I
guess you feel like you're doing a great
job right is what you're saying we're
doing our level best in average what
does that mean what does that mean when
a child is sitting in their own feces
can't take a shower come on man what's
that about none of us would have our
children in that position they are human
beings and I'm trying to figure out and
I get tired of folks saying oh oh they
just beaten up one the Border Patrol oh
baby just be done up on Homeland
Security now what I'm saying is I want
to concentrate on these children and I
want to make sure that there they are
okay I will say it I've said it before
and I'll say it again it's not the deed
that you do to a child it's the memory
it's the memory so it goes on like this
it goes on like this on and on and on
all BS from Elijah Cummings he doesn't
care about these kids at the border if
he cared about these kids he would take
care of the kids in his own district
which is one of the most crime and
poverty run districts in the country
Baltimore look I've taken that train and
I've taken that bus from DC to New York
and back a lot in my life
and that city is a disaster I mean it is
absolutely unconscionable that that is
an American city and that the
politicians in that city would let it
descend that way I am NOT saying this to
defend from streets I'm not saying this
to launch an attack on left-wing
politicians the place is awful take a
look I mean there's videos all over the
Internet of this if you happen to be
nearby or if you're on the train of the
bus you can see it it is a an
unconscionable disgrace and it's a
disgrace that is at the feet of these
politicians who have been there forever
and haven't done anything he does Elijah
Cummings doesn't care about these kids
at all he wants to make a spectacle of
himself and score cheap political points
against Kevin McHale inan who is the
acting
a chess head Elijah Cummings though it's
I it is not fair to blame politicians
for all of the terrible things that
happen in their districts it is fair to
blame me Elijah Cummings because this
guy has been around forever he is a key
power broker in Baltimore he's been in
representing Baltimore in politics since
1983 if you count his service at the
state level not just at the federal
level 1983 what this Cummings do for the
children that he's represented for 36
years we got in Baltimore highest crime
rate second highest violent crime rate
just behind Detroit highest murder rate
50 murders per 100,000 people
Baltimore according to the New York Post
pointing this out has a similar murder
rate to Jamaica Venezuela and El
Salvador don't just take the
right-wingers words for it the Left
admitted this as well and they never
called the New York Times or Bernie
Sanders or any of the other leftists who
pointed this out including the
Democratic mayor of Baltimore they never
called them racist we'll take a look at
that we'll see how Trump responded
whether it helped him or hurt him
politically but first we have got to
thank our friends at Boland branch you
know look I'm on the road I'm here in
Washington to give a couple speeches and
you know when I'm on the road I don't do
very well I don't do very well because I
like my betting the way it is at home I
love my Boland branch sheets here I feel
like I mean they're nice enough sheets
at the hotel they feel like sandpaper
compared to my Boland branch I love them
and it's very important for me as
someone who gets 19 to 21 hours of sleep
per night you know I really got to make
sure I'm sleeping on the best Bolen
branch makes the best everything they
make from bedding to blankets is made
from 100% pure organic cotton so the
first night you sleep in them they are
gonna feel super cool they are going to
feel if you've ever had the privilege I
have once or twice of staying at a
really nice hotel it feels like these
luxury hotels I mean it feels like the
top-of-the-line hotels not what I
usually stay at but the real
top-of-the-line stuff and you can get it
at home it doesn't cost a thousand
dollars like you would have to pay in a
store they go directly to you so you're
getting wholesale prices essentially
they only cost a couple hundred bucks
and you can get the best that's why
everyone who tries Boleyn branch loves
them it's why they have thousands of
five-star reviews it's why three US
presidents
sleep on Boland Branch sheets shipping
is free trying for 30 nights if you
don't love them send them back but you
are for sure going to keep them trust me
I I take my sleeping very seriously
Boleyn branch is the best to get started
right now my listeners get 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets it's a good
deal that's a really good I'm like
giving you free money Boland branch comm
promo code Michel mi CH AE L that is
bold and branch comm for $50 off your
first set of sheets Bo ll and branch
comm promo code Michel mi CH AE L Boleyn
branch comm promo code Michael don't
just take my word for it on Baltimore
and don't just take the word of
right-wingers even left wingers and
left-wing outlets have admitted this
years I mean just a few months ago that
Baltimore is a tragedy the New York
Times in March published a piece called
the tragedy of Baltimore since Freddie
Gray's death in 2015
violent crime has spiked to levels
unseen for a quarter century inside the
crack up of an American city a lot of
other people have come out on this too
so Elijah Cummings launches this
ridiculous attack against the acting
director of DHS and by the way not only
is he Elijah Cummings neglecting his own
district not only should he certainly
not be throwing stones but his attack on
DEA on DHS simply wasn't true here's the
acting director of DHS I would welcome
the opportunity to travel with you to
the donors and to see our men and women
and how hard they are working to care
for children form trillions holding
children that were not their own brought
across by smugglers putting formula and
baby bottles together there there's
no-one defecating in a Mylar blanket we
are taking care of these children thanks
to the resources we finally have they're
moving very quickly through our
facilities to Health and Human Services
to a better situation and I'd be happy
to show you that at the border mr.
chairman generally the case is if
someone is going crazy and grandstanding
and yelling and screaming and becoming
very emotional and then another person
is keeping us cool and just calmly
responding it's gonna be the second
person who's got the truth on his side
and that's very often the case in
political debates between the left which
only can rely on ginning up emotion and
on the right which is answering plainly
with
facts so president Trump came out he
defended his DHS secretary and his
immigration policy and this this is the
tweet that he sent out defending them
going after Elijah Cummings this is what
they're calling racist we'll see if it's
racist we'll see if it helps him we'll
see if it's true he says quote reputa
Liza Cummings has been a brutal bully
shouting and screaming at the great men
and women of border patrol about
conditions at the southern border when
actually his Baltimore district is far
worse and more dangerous his district is
considered the worst in the USA as
proven last week during a congressional
tour the border is clean efficient and
well-run just very crowded Cummings
district is a disgusting rat and rodent
infested mess if he spent more time in
Baltimore maybe he could help clean up
this very dangerous and filthy place Wow
strong tweet three questions first one
is it true the only part of the tweet I
think is not true is I don't think it's
the case that if Cummings spent more
time in his district it would be any
better I think Cummings is a completely
useless corrupt politician who has done
nothing for his district he has very
little achievement to his name over 36
years in politics if anything it seems
that he's made things worse or or has
failed to help as things have gotten
worse in recent years so that's the only
part of the tweet that I think is false
the rest of it is true it's just
demonstrably true Cummings is a bully he
does scream at the people who are trying
to keep our country safe and border
patrol his date his district is one of
the most dangerous places in the country
and poverty-stricken places in the
country obviously the situation at the
border isn't so awful it isn't you know
a concentration camp like aoc says and
it's for a very simple reason I mean
that's the way we know this is
demonstrable because people keep pouring
over our border they keep going to these
facilities even though they know that
they're going to have to be arrested in
these facilities for a while they think
it's a good bet and eventually they're
going to be let out and it's worth doing
that's how you know that it's not a
concentration camp I don't think all of
these a legal aliens are pouring into
Baltimore or West Baltimore or Elijah
Cummings district but they are pouring
into America and they are staying in
these
these detention facilities it is the
case that his district is disgusting
there are rats everywhere there's big
trash problems a huge problems of
poverty there and so it is true second
question is the tweet racist I'm going
to let you in on a little secret if
something is true it's not racist
racism is by definition unjust racial
bigotry is unjust the truth is just the
truth is not unjust also is it racist
even though Baltimore is a mostly black
city Trump has used similar terms to
describe mostly white places he called
New Hampshire a drug infested den a few
years ago he called Bill DeBlasio the
white mayor of New York the worst mayor
every said that city was going to hell
in a handbasket under de Blasio's
leadership so he's used similar language
for white places another reason why it
isn't racist also if you need a third
reason left wingers some of the most
prominent left wingers the most
progressive people in the Democratic
Party have said the exact same things
that Trump said about Baltimore and no
one ever called them racist for those
comments here's Bernie Sanders he could
have been reading a trump tweet and
nobody said peep when he made these
comments about Baltimore country in the
history of the world but anyone who took
the walk that we talked we took around
this neighborhood would not think you're
in a wealthy nation you would think that
you were in a third-world country
where unemployment is over 50% a
community that does not even have decent
quality grocery stores where moms can
buy quality food for their kids a
community in which the dream of getting
a higher education for many kids is as
real as is going to the moon yeah all
true Bernie is right they didn't call
him racist for that and then lest you're
still not convinced the black democratic
progressive liberal left-wing mayor of
Baltimore made almost the
Commons admitted that what Trump said is
right we'll get to that in a second then
we'll get to the big question which is
the big debate on the right or the
tweets politically hurting Trump were
they helping Trump but first speaking of
safety rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer and you know about
ring I've told you about ring for a long
time they've been a great supporter of
the show and they've been a great
supporter of me and my family because
ring makes the smartest coolest video
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery or a surprise visitor you will
get an alert you'll be able to see here
and speak to them all from your phone if
some burglar in the middle of the night
wants to come in and caused your family
harm you'll be able to see here and
speak to them if your mother-in-law
shows up unannounced you will be able to
see here and speak to her obviously that
latter case much much scarier than the
burglar you'll be able to cover both
with your ring I'm a huge believer in
ring I mean I have seen this product up
close and personal I I like that it
makes me feel like The Jeffersons of the
judge not the Jeffersons it's a parade
and slip like the Jetsons like I'm
living in the future it also makes me
feel like The Jeffersons because I'm
moving on up to the east side with my
ring but I love it so much I give it out
to all my friends as housewarming
presents I mean it's just so great and
the other secret reason why I give it
out is it's an amazing deal for what you
get from ring it is an incredible value
as a listener you have a special offer
on a ring starter kit available right
now with a video doorbell and
motion-activated floodlight camera the
starter kit has everything you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home go to ring.com slash knowles
kano wles ring.com slash knowles kayano
wles so the New York Times admits
Baltimore is a tragedy Bernie Sanders
uses almost the same words that Donald
Trump uses to talk about Baltimore here
is the Democrat mayor black mayor of
Baltimore Catherine Pugh just last year
using precisely the same words that
President Trump was using about a year
ago city leaders identified some of the
city's most violent neighborhoods
we should just take all these things to
target who need to smell the rats under
Baltimore's violence reduction
initiative just last week we went with
mayor Pugh was she toured in East
Baltimore neighborhood listen new weapon
and 54 years this enabled Baltimore's
violence reduction initiative is about
taking steps to rid communities of the
cornerstones that contribute to crime my
god you can smell the dead animals
blocks of dilapidated buildings helped
to hide the addiction that's crippled
this community yeah she goes on I mean
she uses the reference to rats the same
one that that President Trump does she
actually uses far tougher language on
Baltimore than Trump does so the
comments they're true they're not racist
that is a given people who were telling
you otherwise are either profoundly
ignorant or disingenuous there is
however a legitimate open question are
these tweets are these fights
politically useful for president Trump
and there's a big debate here tougher
question so is it politically useful
let's say let's let's think about the
opposite let's say that President Trump
doesn't say these things Elijah Cummings
wages his attack on trumps DHS Acting
Secretary on Trump's immigration policy
accuses him of abusing children all
these sort of things and Trump doesn't
say anything the theory here for the
people who don't want him to send the
tweets is that President Trump will
avoid a few days of an unnecessary news
cycle that calls him racist I think this
is a fantasy
they already call him a racist every day
on the news channels the the the
left-wing controls the mainstream media
in this country they're already doing it
so what is the difference you know the
the more establishment type Republicans
say avoid anything that might even
possibly be twisted unfairly unjustly in
to Democrats calling you a racist this
is like the MIT Romney idea I'm not
going to talk about anything that could
even even if it's remotely cultural
because if it's sort of cultural then
they might twist it
- something racial and then it might be
called racist and we're not gonna do
that we're gonna totally lay off that's
the Romney strategy that is not how
President Trump rolls if you remember 10
years ago I guess now 14 years ago
President Trump got into this big fight
with Rosie O'Donnell of all people
Rosie started the fight on the view she
said the Trump was bankrupt and Trump
viciously absurdly hilariously very
cruelly responded to her with a week's
long tirade in the media here's just
some of how President Trump responded to
Rosie O'Donnell well Rosie O'Donnell is
disgusting I mean both inside and out
you take a look at her she's a slob she
talks like like a truck driver
Rosie attacked me personally because I
was very happy when her talk-show failed
the other thing that failed and this was
a real monster
and everybody was suing there was her
magazine her magazine called Rosie was a
total disaster so I loved it I gloat
over it I think it's wonderful because I
like to see bad people fail Rosie failed
I'm happy about it she's basically a
disaster well she called me a snake oil
salesman and you know coming from Rosie
that's pretty low because when you look
at her and when you see the mind the
mind is is weak I don't see it I don't
get it I never understood how does she
even get on television I believe Barbara
made a terrible mistake putting a run
and I think Barbara's probably paying a
big price if I were running the view I'd
fire Rosie I mean I'd look at right on
that fat ugly face of hers I'd say Rosie
you're fired we're all a little chubby
but Rosie's just worse than most of us
but it's not the chubbiness rosie is a
very unattractive person both inside and
out Rosie's a person that's very lucky
to have her girlfriend and she better be
careful or I'll send one of my friends
over to pick up her girlfriend why would
she stay with Rosie if she had another
choice she's trying to use ABC and the
view to get even with me but with me we
fight back yes you fight back Donald
Trump you fight I mean that is most of
us who were kind of nice guys you know
we've tried to be polite and have
manners we would never even consider
saying something like that to a woman
okay we wouldn't we just
want to do it president Trump is not
that nice guy he's not mr. nice guy he
might be in his personal relationships a
nice guy but when you attack one of his
enterprises he punches back twice as
hard doesn't matter if you're a thirty
year representative from a district
doesn't matter if you are Rosie
O'Donnell he will collaborate you by the
way though in his defense I and I find
those comments really really distasteful
but in his defense this is what a lot of
people on the right have been urging
Republicans do for to do for a decade
when they get hit from their political
opponents to punch back twice as hard
but now that someone is actually doing
it to Elijah Cummings to Nancy Pelosi to
the Democrats now that you're actually
seeing someone do it all of a sudden
some people are uncomfortable with it
and so the question is are these tweets
helping Trump politically or hurting
Trump politically is punching back twice
as hard helping Trump politically or
hurting Trump politically I think you
get the answer in the second stage of
this whole stupid non traversée and the
second stage of it is now after Trump's
comments al Sharpton
al Sharpton one of the most despicable
people in America is going to Baltimore
to hold a press conference today over
Trump's outrageous remarks and so guess
what happened
president Trump punched right back at
him he tweeted out just a few hours ago
quote I've known Al for 25 years went to
fights with him and Don King always got
along well he loved Trump he would ask
me for favors often al is a con man a
troublemaker always looking for a score
just doing his thing must have
intimidated Comcast NBC because he had a
show on NBC hates whites and cops whoa
makes what he said about Rosie O'Donnell
look polite makes it look soft now
people are calling this tweet racist
he's saying it's racist to call al
Sharpton racist let's ask the same three
questions really quick is it true I'm
not sure if al Sharpton hates whites he
definitely hates Jews right people
forget because their memories are really
short is
politics al sharpton helped to launch
the Crown Heights riots against Jews he
once at a rally in Harlem he said quote
if the Jews want to get it on
tell them to pin their yarmulkes back
and come over to my house
broadly speaking even if he hasn't
spoken that explicitly against white
people generally he regularly shows
racial resentment against whites and
general resentment against cops so that
part is true he is also a con man this
guy is a shakedown artist who extorts
money from companies and individuals by
threatening to call them racist it's his
entire career and he's made a lot of
money doing it also speaking of con
artists he launched his whole career on
a rape hoax a racial rape hoax
Tawana Brawley a name that people don't
remember anymore because it looked so
bad for Sharpton in the left
Tawana Brawley said she'd been raped by
four white men cops and an attorney in
1987 they said she was found in a trash
bag that was covered with racial slurs
covered in feces can you imagine the
hate crime of the century and it was a
total lie was a total hoax and Al
Sharpton was the biggest peddler of her
lives she was accused and sued
successfully for defamation so is is
what Trump said about Sharpton true 100
percent now is what he said racist no I
get why because if it's true it's not
racist
racism is unjust what he said perfectly
just perfectly true now Sharpton is a
racist that is certainly true and it's
not racist to point out that Al Sharpton
is a racist then you get to the third
question this is the tough one but I
think this case really makes it a little
clearer which way it is is it
politically smart I think it is I think
it is politically smart to throw these
tweets out there to go right at Elijah
Cummings and especially to go right at
Al Sharpton all right this is the only
place where I differ from some of my
colleagues some of my other friends on
the right we all agree what he said is
true we all agree what he said is not
racist the only place where I differ
from some of my friends and colleagues
on the right I think they are
politically helpful
okay so the argument that they're
politically harmful is that without the
Trump tweets the news cycle would be
terrible for Democrats but now with the
Trump tweets it's good for Democrats
that isn't true the Democrats control
the news cycle every news cycle by
definition is basically good for
Democrats if it's not perfectly good at
least they will they will coddle the
Democrats and they'll try to invent non
traverses about conservatives and
Republicans they did this to Bush they
just made up a number of fake scandals
because Bush didn't really have scandals
so they made up the Valerie Plame affair
totally ginned up non traversée just to
turn the news cycles also maybe more
importantly I don't think this is a bad
news cycle for Trump I don't think these
tweets have made a bad news cycle let's
just look at the last two tweet storms
let's look at the effect of those tweet
storms we'll get to it in one second
then we'll get to the death penalty
which is coming back at the federal
level because the current Attorney
General wants to actually enforce the
law that is on the books we'll get to
that we'll get to some good news at the
Supreme Court as well for the southern
border and the border wall and
immigration but first I've got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube before I
do that look I'm giving you good
discounts on premium luxury bed sheets
today I'm giving you all sorts of stuff
great deals on home protection let me
give you a job because the daily wire is
growing rapidly I kid you not every time
I look around I see a new face in there
we are growing rapidly I am thrilled
about that and we're wrong rapidly
because of the support of all of you
means we're also excited to be offering
more opportunities to become part of our
in-house team head on over right now to
daily wire comm slash careers see AR
EE RS to see if any of our job openings
would be right for you or someone you
know it's kind of weird because when Ben
sent me this information he said you
know to point out we got a lot of jobs
in different departments and the host of
the Michael Nolt show position is going
to be opening up soon which didn't that
doesn't make a lot of sense to me I
don't know how because obviously I am
the host but anyway that's what Ben was
telling me head on over to daily
wire.com slash careers come on and join
the fun go to daily wire comm we will be
right back
a lot more
okay
is this politically useful for Trump to
focus on the tweets to go right after
these cultural issues to go after al
Sharpton and call him a racist to go
after Elijah Cummings and call him a
failure look at the last two tweet
storms two weeks ago remember he went
after AOC and the squad and he said to
go back where they came from and we all
said that wasn't a good line we all said
he should have written it differently
however two weeks ago Nancy Pelosi was
winning the fight against AOC and Ilhan
Omar
they both had awful approval ratings
Pelosi was pouncing on them after those
Trump tweets which were in part
incorrect and which were import
misguided and wrong but after those
Trump tweets Democrats rallied behind
the unpopular squad and were taking
photos with them Nancy Pelosi
hosted AOC in her office you know she
hosted the real Speaker of the House AOC
in her office took a big smiley photo
the effect I'm not I'm not even talking
about the intrinsic goodness of the
tweets or the justice of them I'm just
talking about the political effect a
political effect of that first round of
tweets helped Trump got got the
Democrats talking about impeachment
again which is politically a loser for
them this year you're seeing the same
strategy in this tweet storm after the
Trump tweets the Democrats are now
rallying behind Al Sharpton al Sharpton
the mainstream media NBC News Kamala
Harris are calling al Sharpton a race
hustling extortionist a quote civil
rights leader that's not going to work
al Sharpton is extremely unpopular even
in his own neighborhoods
there was a Quinnipiac poll a few years
ago that actually measured Al Sharpton's
favorability his favorability in New
York is just 29% in New York how do you
think he plays in Peoria how do you
think he plays in in real America you
know the the middle of the country
between the two coasts in New York al
Sharpton is just 29% approval and he's
got a 53% disapproval rating what is it
in the rest of the country rallying
behind Al Sharpton is a totally losing
position and by going after Al Sharpton
Trump has caused the left to defend him
same strategy when Trump was criticizing
Colin Kaepernick you know a lot of
trumps skeptical conservatives who are
genuinely pretty nice guys so they don't
like it when the president's criticizing
athletes a lot of them said please don't
criticize the NFL for kneeling please
don't criticize the football players
what is the cumulative effect of all of
this the American flag is very popular
it's not good to be supporting people
who disrespect the American flag the
cumulative effect of all of these tweets
you now have Democrats opposing the
American flag opposing 4th of July
parades opposing our national boundaries
and borders supporting socialists and
the squad and in the case of these
latest tweets you've got now Democrats
opposing cops and supporting al Sharpton
even just on the cop thing even the
anti-law enforcement thing that the left
is now reacting to President Trump on
and opposing law enforcement whether
it's ice or whether it's local cops
Gallup polling shows that cops are
basically the most popular institution
in the country they're the third most
popular institution in the entire
country right after the military and
small business so the effect of these
tweets is you've got the Democrats
defending the least popular people
institutions and action in this country
and they're identifying them right now
they're they're identifying Trump with
the most popular institutions including
the American flag now it's not all
political bright side for Trump to with
these tweets I ignite otally acknowledge
there is a political downside because he
is a fighter because he's an insult
comic he makes himself unlikable to a
lot of people but president Trump's bet
is not to make himself acceptable that
was the Romney bet be the least
offensive don't talk about anything
other than Obama's bad economy
be totally milquetoast nice smiling no
offense romney lost and trump one that
tells you something
and by the way trump is never gonna make
himself acceptable in polite society
that's not who he is Trump's strategy is
to smear his opponents just as bad if
not worse then they smear him as a
matter of personal compartment and grace
this is not great obviously don't frown
on that I don't try to live my life that
way as a matter of political strategy
though it may be essential particularly
in this present moment and I've thrown
very long time said conservatives need
to sharpen our rhetoric so the left goes
out they call us transphobic bigots
because we don't want to inject little
children with puberty blocking hormones
well we should go right back at the left
and call them sick perverts and child
abusers from what they're doing to those
kids that's what President Trump is
doing he's taking that strategy he's not
making himself the most acceptable guy
in the world his entire focus is on
making his opponents unacceptable that's
the strategy and politically it has paid
off for him we actually have some data
points here it has worked for him worked
for him in 2016 is it gonna work for him
in the future I'm not sure I'm not
predicting the future we'll get an
answer on that in 2020 but from the from
what we see here it does seem to me like
it's a pretty good strategy it seems to
me the tweets are working and more
importantly because we're just talking
about political realities if Trump is
not ever going to be the perfectly nice
behaved guy who's Mitt Romney and smiles
and helps a little Rainey's cross the
street if he's not going to be that guy
if he's gonna be a puncher and a fighter
and an insult comic then this is the
strategy he has to pursue fortunately it
seems to be working but we'll see if it
keeps working in 2020 we have to talk
briefly about the death penalty this is
a story that's not getting a lot of
traction William bar the Attorney
General is now going to be enforcing the
federal death penalty again for the
first time in 16 years we have not
executed
a federally condemned criminal since
2003 and the reason the story isn't
getting a lot of traction is because the
left says the death penalty is the worst
thing in the world and the right is kind
of divided on the issue a lot of
conservatives don't really understand
what the death penalty is for so I will
defend the death penalty I will defend
as your resident bloodthirsty autocratic
theocratic whatever lines they want to
use I'll defend the death penalty so the
left here's their argument cory booker
says the death penalty is immoral and
ineffective senator Spartacus Ayana
Presley the Ringo Starr of the squad
says quote the death penalty has no
place in a just society
Ilhan Omar she took a break from
sympathizing with al-qaeda to call the
death penalty a heinous totalitarian
practice often used against innocent
people the very definition of cruel and
unusual punishment oh by the way all of
those people support abortion on demand
at any stage of pregnancy they all
support killing innocent babies up until
the moment they're born which is the law
now in New York because of the current
Democratic governor there in the case of
the governor of Virginia he supports
killing babies after they've been born
but they don't think that we should kill
violent awful terrible murderers that is
unjust that is the worst crime in the
world the left as always gets it exactly
backwards
who is this going to affect five
criminals who are going to be executed
they are murderers their child murderers
and child torturers people who tortured
and killed their own children white
supremacists murderers these are the
worst people on earth but according to
the left all those people should live
and innocent babies should die one of
these stupidest arguments against the
death penalty is an argument that
disingenuous left wingers use against
conservatives they say well if you're
pro-life then you need to be consistent
that it's inconsistent to be pro-life
but then support the death penalty not
true at all there is nothing
inconsistent about thinking we shouldn't
kill innocent babies and also the state
can execute criminals nothing
inconsistent I mean this the left does
their politics and slogans and slogans
are usually pretty stupid the right
doesn't use slogans too much but one of
them that we use is the term pro-life
which basically defines what we think
but if you want me to clarify I'll
clarify I'm Pro innocent life I think I
think we should save innocent babies
from being killed and I think that the
civil authority can kill criminals of
course as has every civilization that
has ever existed for all of human
history and the reason for that is I'm
Pro justice justice is a wonderful thing
there's two reasons why I think support
for the death penalty has dropped even
among conservatives on the one hand
we've lost a sense of justice we think
that the only purpose of the criminal
justice system you hear that we're
justice in there is to rehabilitate
criminals and obviously you're not going
to rehabilitate them if they're gonna
hang from a noose actually there's an
argument there that that hanging or
facing capital punishment will actually
really clear up your mind and it might
not save you in this world but it might
reform you for the world to come but
still let's let's say it's not going to
rehab you okay there are three purposes
of punishment one of them is
rehabilitation the other one is
deterrence and the death penalty when
it's actually carried out is a great
deterrent and the third one is
retribution and this the retribution
people now say that that doesn't matter
at all we don't want to actually punish
people because they committed a crime we
want to punish them to rehabilitate them
we want to punish them to deter other
crime no the most important one is the
retribution because of the justice
because of the injustice that they've
committed the civil authority has to
exact justice from the criminal the
reason this is the most important one is
because look we could all use a little
rehabilitation we could all do things
that we could all improve on our lives
and do things that we shouldn't or stop
doing things that we shouldn't do it we
could all deter other people from doing
things the reason that you get arrested
and prosecuted and sentenced you
is because you committed a crime the
differentiated fit differentiating
factor between me and those guys who are
going to face the death penalty is not
that I can't use some rehabilitation I'm
extraordinarily imperfect there's a lot
I could improve on in my life the
difference is they committed the crime
and I did not the the retribution is the
key there so that's that's ones that
we've lost the sense of justice the
other reason why I think support for the
death penalty is fallen is that we've
become functionally a secular atheistic
materialistic society and this really
matters because for all of human history
everywhere in the world we've had a
sense that mankind has something beyond
this world in our civilization we
believe that man has an eternal soul we
believe that there is justice after you
die that the soul goes on I certainly
believe that the smartest people in
human history have believed that
virtually every civilization has
believed that and now in sort of the
madness of the late 19th century and
20th century we've become increasingly
atheist I think without reason
whatsoever I think it's a silly
intellectual fad that is going to pass
away but because of that the the thought
that we could maybe kill an innocent
person is so horrifying because what we
assume is at that point that person is
that their life is over there is no
justice there's no heaven there's no
hell there's no nothing
there's no eternal soul or just kind of
meat puppets it's the John Lennon song I
mean we become a country that's in a
civilization that's basically accepted
that John Lennon song is our theology
imagine there's no heaven it's easy if
you try and that's because we believe
that then the the very fact that the
criminal justice system is imperfect and
maybe it'll only be one in a thousand
maybe it'll be one in 10,000 but at some
point some innocent guy is going to be
killed if we carry out the death penalty
with any sort of significant size that's
so horrifying to us we immediately back
away from that now I think that's just
emotional that's not a not really an
intellectual point of view
because the criminal justice system is
always going to be imperfect do we
really think it's better it's more
compassionate to accidentally sentence
an innocent man to forty years in prison
robbed him of his entire life and he's
just sitting there on a bench decaying
for forty years rather than accidentally
sending an innocent man to the firing
squad
now they're both horrific I mean they're
both just so awful but all human
institutions have to accept that degree
of imperfection we want to improve them
we want to make them better we will
we've obviously been able to do that now
with DNA testing but if you really
believe that we're all just meat puppets
and the lights go out when you die it's
just on an emotional level it's so much
more horrifying that you've got to back
away even if you're a little bit of a
right winger this is too bad because a
society that doesn't understand capital
punishment has lost an important sense
of justice and justices a key virtue
it's lost an important sense of its own
purpose lost an important sense of the
natural order and the natural law I'm
glad that the Attorney General has moral
clarity on this I'm glad that just as a
basic level that we're just enforcing
the law now as opposed to just
unilaterally like some self-appointed
king deciding which laws to enforce and
which laws not to enforce but I wish
more people would think think real hard
about their objections to the death
penalty and maybe where they come from
and maybe why society has changed its
view on this so dramatically over time
before we go really quick great news
from the Supreme Court also not being
covered enough the court has ruled 5-2
for the president Trump can use pentagon
funds to build part of the border wall
this is a big fight the Democrats
wouldn't give him funding for the border
wall that wouldn't give him much funding
and so he tried to use the military the
Pentagon funds to do it a few different
places he's trying to do this this
Supreme Court decision has to do with
specifically 2.5 billion dollars of
funds from the Pentagon that will
allowed Trump to build up to 100 miles
of the wall this is a double-whammy win
for the White House and I was going
after the White House last week because
Trump has a major political
vulnerability going into 2020 which is
that one of his central campaign
promises build the wall hasn't happened
and he said that it's happened but he
ain't telling the truth there was a CBP
report that came out Customs and Border
Protection that showed that not one mile
not one inch of new wall has been built
since he was elected in 2016 no he's
replaced old fencing it's very difficult
to build new fencing okay I get it but
if he goes into 2020 and he says listen
I've fulfilled a lot of promises but I'm
definitely gonna build the wall next
time people aren't gonna believe him
this was a major central promise he's
gotta deliver on the reason this is a
double-whammy win for Trump is he ran
basically on two things in 2016
judges and immigration judges we're
gonna replace Scalia with a good judge
we can't afford to lose the Supreme
Court we had a lot of federal judges on
judges and immigration and in this
particular case you had the Trump
appointed judges giving him the win on
the border wall you had it was a 5-4
decision without the Trump judges never
could have happened that's a big win it
allows him to appeal to some
conservatives who are a little skeptical
of course and of Cavanagh and say look
we got it where it counted these guys
the judges are important give me four
more years and I'll build a hundred
miles more hopefully a thousand miles
more of wall and I'll get you more
Supreme Court judges if Ruth Bader
Ginsburg ever admits or rather if her
handlers ever admit that we've got a
weekend at Bernie's situation going on
just saying whenever those seats open up
that's gonna be the pitch I think it's a
major victory which is why the
mainstream media aren't covering that
much now the question is can he start to
build that wall because it's not enough
just to get the money you got to start
doing it all right that's our show we
have a lot more to get to but there's no
time I'll be giving a speech tomorrow at
the young America's Foundation in
Washington DC I think we're gonna
livestream it so be sure to tune in for
that
otherwise I am then heading to New York
I will see you back in la-la land on
Thursday
no show tomorrow no show Wednesday but
we will make it up to you I promise
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show see them
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 everyone its
Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin
show you know it's become pretty common
to hear people in the media say the
Trump's tweets are a distraction we must
ignore them and address the serious
issues not true right now the most
important thing happening in this
country is Trump's rude and pugilistic
Twitter war against the leftist servants
of a global elite who use charges of
racism to silence dissent if we lose
that war we lose everything we'll talk
about it on the Andrew Klavan show I'm
Andrew Clavin